In this exercise, we'll be
looking at a problem, also
know as the coupons collector's
problem.
We have a set of K coupons,
or grades in our case.
And each time slot
we're revealed
with one random grade.
And we'd like to know how long
it would take for us to
collect all K grades.
In our case, K is equal to 6.
Now the key to solving
the problem
is essentially twofolds.
First, we'll have to find a way
to intelligently define
sequence random variables that
captured, essentially,
stopping time of this process.
And then we'll employ the idea
of linearity of expectations
in breaking down this value
in simpler terms.
So let's get started.
We'll define Yi as the number
of papers till we see
the i-th new grade.
What does that mean?
Well, let's take a look
at an example.
Suppose, here we have a timeline
from no paper yet,
first paper, second paper,
third paper,
so on, and so forth.
Now, if we got grade A on the
first slot, grade A minus on
second slot, A again on the
third slot, let's say there's
a fourth's slot, we got B.
According to this process, we
see that Y1 is always 1,
because whatever we got
on the first slot
will be a new grade.
Now, Y2 is 2, because
the second paper is,
again, a new grade.
On the third paper we got a
grade, which is the same as
the first grade.
So that would not
count as any Yi.
And the third time we saw new
grade would now be paper four.
According to this notation,
we're interested in knowing
what is the expected value of E
of Y6, which is the time it
takes to receive
all six grades.
So so far this notation isn't
really helping us in solving
the problem, but kind of just
staying a different way.
It turns out, it's much easier
to look at the following
variable derived from the Yis.
We'll define Xi as the
difference between Yi
plus 1 minus Yi.
And in [? words, ?] it says, Xi
is a number of papers you
need until you see the i plus
1-th new grade, after you have
received i new grade so far.
So in this case, X1 will be if
we call 0, Y0, will be the
difference between Y1 and
Y0, which is always 1--
that's X1.
And the difference between
these two will be X2.
Y3 and Y2--
Sorry.
It should be Y X0,
1, 2, and so on.
OK?
Through this notation we see
that Y6 now can be written as
the summation of i equal
to 0, 2, 5, X, i.
So all I did was to break down
i6 into a sequence of
summation of the differences,
like Y. 6 Minus Y5, Y5 minus
Y4, and so on.
It turns out, this expression
will be very useful.
OK.
So now that we have the two
variables Y and X, let's see
if it will be easier to look
at the distribution of X in
studying this process.
Let's say, we have seen
a new grade so far--
one.
How many trials would it
take for us to see
the second new grade?
It turns out it's
not that hard.
In this case, we know there is
a total of six grades, and we
have seen one of them.
So that leaves us five
more grades that
we'll potentially see.
And therefore, on any random
trial after that, there is a
probability of 5 over 6 that
we'll see a new grade.
And hence, we know that X1 has
a distribution geometric with
a success probability,
or a parameter, 5/6.
Now, more generally, if we
extend this idea further, we
see that Xi will have a
geometric distribution of
parameter 6 minus i over 6.
And this is due to the fact that
so far we have already
seen i new grades.
And that will be the success
probability of seeing a
further new grade.
So from this expression, we know
that the expected value
of Xi will simply be the inverse
of the parameter of
the geometric distribution,
which is 6 over 6 minus i or 6
times 1 over 6 minus i.
And now we're ready to compute
a final answer.
So from this expression we know
expected value of Y6 is
equal to the expected value of
sum of i equal to 0 to 5 Xi.
And by the linearity of
expectation, we can pull out
the sum and write it as 2,
5 expected value of Xi.
Now, since we know that
expective of Xi is the
following expression.
We see that this term is equal
to 6 times expected value of i
equals 0, 5, 1 over 6 minus i.
Or written in the other way
this is equal to 6 times i
equal to 0, 2, 5.
In fact, 1, 2, 5, 1 over i.
And all I did here was to,
essentially, change the
variable, so that these two
summations contained exactly
the same terms.
And this will give us the
answer, which is 14.7.
Now, more generally, we can
see that there's nothing
special about number 6 here.
We could have substituted 6 with
a number, let's say, K.
And then we'll get E of YK,
let's say, there's more than
six labels.
And this will give us K times
summation i equal to 1, so K
minus 1, 1 over i.
Interestingly, it turns out
this quantity has an
[? asymptotic ?]
expression that, essentially,
is roughly equal to K times
the natural logarithm of K.
And this is known as the
scaling [? la ?]
for the coupon collector's
problem that says,
essentially, takes about
K times [? la ?]
K many trials until we collect
all K coupons.
And that'll be the end
of the problem.
See you next time.